please tell me if any other woman relates to this
you meet a man
and you know that you have a partner
or you're uninterested
you're not on the market
you know your current situation
but you meet a man
and he is unaware of your situation
and he is very excited to meet you and have a conversation with you
and you're like oh
I know you're only being nice to me
cause you think you might have a chance to have sex with me
and I know that there's no chance of that
but you're really hopeful that there is
and so you're trying to like
pace their niceness for them
because you're like
I'm not gonna give you what you're looking for
and I know that
and I know what you're looking for just by the way you're talking to me
so I'm gonna try to like
walk you off that bridge by like
as the conversations going
so as to not lead you on
because this is gonna get really awkward
and then when they finally get to the part where they kinda like
ask you for your number or ask you
you know they they
they do the thing
and you're like oh
you fucked around
and now you have to find out
and then immediately
like all of their niceness and
and happiness and cordialness
like goes away
and you're like uh huh
yeah that's what I thought thanks ugh
I hate those interactions